you may have forgotten that there is a
presidential campaign going on you may I
know the riots and the plagues and the
giving away half of Oklahoma probably
has you a little distracted but actually
we are in the midst of presidential
campaign season even though there's no
campaign maybe there's no campaign by
design maybe the fact that there's no
campaign is helping one candidate such
as Joe Biden over the other one I don't
know here to help me understand it is
one of my favorite Democrats in the
country
Jessica Tarlov contributor for Fox News
Channel and senior director of research
and consumer insight for bustled the
owner and operator of bustle comm romper
and elite daily and and Jessica's been a
Democratic strategist with Doug shown
where she advise domestic and
international clients on all sorts of
political matters and hopefully now she
can advise me on what the Democratic
Party is doing Jessica thank you for
being here thank you for having me so
I'm watching this campaign me a layman
what do I know and I see that the the
democratic party's presumptive nominee
Joe Biden is not campaigning he actually
gave this sort of small press gaggle
where he said he's not going to campaign
and he's sort of blaming it on the virus
and he says it's the doctor's orders and
now you're already seen calls in the New
York Times for there not to be
presidential debates to me it looks like
Joe Biden is trying to get out of the
hardships of the campaign maybe because
he is famously prone to gaffes is my is
my read on this thing too cynical or do
I have a point I think both can be true
but I'm just feeling generous thank you
honey Friday in Hollywood listen I think
that there are real genuine health
concerns for him he's in the most
at-risk category right and campaigning
is shaking hands and kissing babies
right both of which things we are for
forbidden from doing and you are correct
that he has stuck his foot in it you
know a few times when he's out and
uncensored though I would all
so add to that that he has had some of
his most charming moments as well when
he got with people especially when he is
connecting about healthcare issues right
and you know there was moment early in
the companion car new young boy who also
suffers from a stutter you know those
are the moments that really exposed the
type of person Joe Biden is and why a
lot of people even moderate Republicans
are now supporting his campaign so I
think that there's health there is
concern about him uncensored for you
know an hour 90 minutes without you know
for long periods of time that exists at
contemporaneously and I think that the
Democrats really want to send a message
that we are taking this virus extremely
seriously and the contrast between the
Tulsa rally for instance and how careful
were being you know we have a virtual
convention that's going to be out of
Milwaukee where the vice president will
be where he'll accept the Democratic
nomination but there will be very few
people there really demonstrates the
seriousness of the pandemic in the minds
of our party and I think that's
important I would also add that an
advantage that Joe Biden has that the
president doesn't have in the same way
in terms of galvanizing voters is he has
such a strong stable of surrogates if
you look even at yesterday so he
announced his build that better plan
right his economic plan yes and he had
Kamala Harris out there he had Amy
Klobuchar he had sherrod Brown he had
Julian Castro Elizabeth Warren did an
event as well and so it's kind of like
choose-your-own-adventure
for Democrats right like you can get
your favorite person right basically
every day doing something fun and I
think he's comfortable with that I think
that's a good point because so much of
the Biden candidacy from the very
beginning seems to me that he's kind of
nothing I don't even mean that in a
disparaging way I just mean Joe Biden is
this kind of blank slate neutral totally
typical Democratic candidate and so you
can if you if he relies on surrogates
then he can push you know toward one
demographic or toward one one
ideological part of the the demo
any party or he can push toward another
and I guess this is the problem of of
the basement campaign you know that
you're right that he has had at least a
couple charming moments on the campaign
trail
it offers voters a chance to see him and
and to connect to him and he's also had
many gaffes on the campaign trail and
when you just stick at home and you
don't go out in campaign you don't get
either of those things so is the is the
calculation right now the democratic
party that the the negatives would
outweigh the positives the gaffes would
outweigh the charming moments and that
it does the democratic party really
believe that that Joe Biden can sit on
his couch until November third and then
move from his couch to the Oval Office
so I was push back on that he's actually
been out way more than I think folks
certainly on the right are giving him
credit for you know he he was out in
Scranton yesterday he was out on
Memorial Day he went and that would
George Floyd's family he was in Houston
he hasn't just been in his basement and
I know that was kind of a favorite line
about this now he's certainly not
walking from you know the White House to
marine one every day and talking to a
gaggle of reporters that are understand
that contrast but he I don't think has
been as inactive as people would make it
out and I don't think the calculation is
that it's better if you stuck inside
versus being out there and but I do
think it loops back to the gravity of
the moment in terms of kovat and the
fact that Joe Biden's popularity stems
from and I don't want to say I
completely endorsed or kind of Blake
blank-slate
candidacy argument but I actually wrote
a piece this week in the hill about his
why people are enthusiastic about him
and it's because of policy so Joe Biden
is an amalgamation of Democrats favorite
policy right like raising the minimum
wage expanding health care having a
public option his climate plan his jobs
plan and people on the right are
animated by Trump the man and on the
Left they're animated by a collection of
policy I would actually
I would push back a little bit I know
this is the popular view even among
people on the right is that people just
love Trump the man I'm kind of more with
Ann Coulter on this and wrote this whole
book with a very very enthusiastic title
in Trump We Trust
but her argument was basically yeah
people actually everyone thinks you like
Trump the man in it regardless of what
his policies are but actually I think a
lot of people like the policies he's
he's talking about different things on
trade for instance and a lot of other
Republicans they like the policies in a
way in spite of some of his his
personality issues and I don't know I
think there's an argument to be had
there but surely you're right the the
Biden campaign is a kind of amalgamation
of all these Democratic policies that
people really like on the question of
the man you know we've heard a lot about
Trump's horrible personalities
narcissist he's got he's losing it it
would seem pretty clear to me that Joe
Biden today is not the Joe Biden that we
knew 10 years ago and he's not the Joe
Biden we knew 20 years ago do you think
this cognitive decline issue is one a
fair argument into something that's
going to weigh heavily in November I
don't think it's a fair argument and I
think that if you watched him yesterday
or the speech that he gave in
Philadelphia or in the fundraiser with
Barack Obama like a couple weeks ago the
one the day he raised 11 million dollars
I don't see that he has always had
moments of being a step slow some of
that I think is due to the stutter and
you know overthinking what he's going to
say and making sure that he can get the
right word but yeah he has can see he
has senior moments every once in a while
and I don't think it's a real issue for
voters particularly in this election
because it seems everyone is hip to the
fact that this is a binary choice yes
right in twenty sixteen people floated
you know flirted with third party
candidates they thought oh maybe I'll
stay home no one feels that way right
now and if they are disenchanted with
both candidates which frankly is a lot
of people yes Biden is up something like
50 points in terms of approval right and
so I would push back on that and I've
also and I think we've talked about this
when you joined us over at Fox that I'm
I am personally very uncomfortable with
armchair medical diagnosis your people
we don't know and that was true with
Hillary when there was the OSHA
Parkinson's I have never said I think
Trump is suffering from anything besides
arrogance and I wouldn't comment as well
on what I think is going on with Biden I
just I just don't think it's appropriate
and I think it's really dangerous
especially going into an election just
having those conversations you know when
Trump last night on Hannity he said like
you know I had I went to Walter Reed
which we didn't know I had a cognitive
test and it surprised them because I
aced it like I don't even want to touch
that you know a ridiculous thing to say
but what do we know right we're sitting
in our studios pontificating about stuff
that doctors know way better than us so
you know I stay out of that I have to
say Jessica you have made a much better
argument for Joe Biden than I think Joe
Biden has been making himself I think
the Democratic Party would do much
better if their nominee were I don't
know say Jessica Tarlov instead of Joe
Biden but but maybe maybe one day that's
right if they if they get lucky if they
get through this election I don't know
obviously the numbers don't look good
for President Trump but in politics
anything can happen we still have
several more months Jessica thank you so
much for being here you can always see
Jessica on on Fox News you can see her
at bustled you can read her latest op-ed
in the hill she is everywhere always
always great to talk to you
[Music]
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description